how cool is it to see Drake wearing
y'all cause C there first of all I
don't give a what anybody says I
don't believe Drake wore that having
ever even heard any of our music I think
he wore that as a fashion thing okay I
don't doubt that because I think that's
what's happening is over time you know
we're old school I've seen in a fashion
magazine an ICP shirt for $500 it was
like ripped like it look you get a cut
it was like a fashion vintage
one it was a vintage one no it was like
fashion it was the design of the shirt
you know what you guys need to get a
piece of company that's what I'm saying
that like like it's a it's a fashion
thing get what I'm saying like Drake
have the was it the Jersey a a ring
Master Jersey which is our second album
like the second Joker's card you know
what the is Drake doing wearing
that